[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 20 novembre
et justement ce vendredi c'est la
journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant avec la crise sanitaire nous
ferons un focus sur la ville de
guyancourt qui s'est adaptée pour tous
même organisé quelques animations elle
qui est à ville à nous des enfants
un label attribué par l'unicef nous
recevrons philippe journée quand chargé
de la communication pour le comité
évinois de cette association
après la haute cour ce mardi c'est à la
ferme de gally à saint-cyr-l'ecole qu'un
nouveau foyer de contamination de grippe
aviaire a été découvert les oiseaux
concernés ont été euthanasiés
préventivement et enfin au dernier
pointage l'yvelinois louis burton est
toujours sixième au classement du vendée
globe le skipper de bureau vallée 2 est
désormais dans le pot-au-noir et comme
je vous le disais en titre un deuxième
foyer de contamination de la grippe
aviaire a été découvert jeudi soir cette
fois ci c'est dans les yvelines une oie
s'est retrouvés contaminés à la ferme de
gally à saint-cyr-l'ecole la ferme
accueille l animal pendant quelques
jours pour un client on écoute la
réaction de brügg au bruno guézel pardon
responsable de la communication
j'avais évidemment triste malheureux
surpris parce que encore une fois on
emporte pensons à nos animaux on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à être touché
par mesure de précaution et pour éviter
toute propagation de la grippe aviaire
l'ensemble des oiseaux de la ferme de
gally a dû être euthanasié entre la
crise sanitaire et maintenant la grippe
aviaire
la ferme de gally n'est pas épargnée
mais veut re était de rester optimiste
un problème de ligne les salons des
répercussions sur nos activités
cette nouvelle crise également une fois
ce ne sont pas comparables elles sont
pas liés on doit aller de l'avant et
faire face et et on va continuer
d'accueillir nos clients en respectant
toutes les mesures sanitaires
je rappelle que la grippe aviaire n'est
pas transmissible à l'homme
cette contamination à la ferme de gally
le deuxième cas détecté en france trois
jours après l'annoncé d'un premier foyer
en haute corse par le ministère de
l'agriculture
une enquête épidémiologique est en train
d'être mené afin d'identifier le lien
entre ses deux foyers et l'origine de la
contamination
[Musique]
avant de recevoir philippe journée quand
de l'unicef des yvelines pour parler de
ce vendredi 20 novembre journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
focus sur la commune de guyancourt ville
amie des enfants depuis 2006 cette année
avec la crise sanitaire la municipalité
s'est adapté pour organiser quelques
animations autour de cette journée
reportage c'est une journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant un
peu particulière ce vendredi 20 novembre
à guyancourt
avec la crise sanitaire impossible
d'organiser le grand rassemblement avec
500 enfants de cm2 et de 6e comme c'est
la coutume mais la ville a tout de même
souhaité organiser quelque chose et
c'est donc adapté donc on a décidé de
mettre en place une formule un peu
différente avec vous savez on a un
conseil municipal on en vient de fêter
les 30 ans et donc on aura des
ambassadeurs de ce conseil municipal des
enfants qui vont dans les écoles cm1 cm2
voir des classes directement et
expliquer ce que c'est que la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant a été créé en 1989
les responsables politiques se sont
engagés à construire un monde digne des
enfants
c'est dans ce but que guyancourt
organise chaque année des animations
l'objectif c'est d'expliquer un petit
peu aux enfants les sensibilités les
sensibiliser pendant cette convention
leur expliquer tous les droits qui sont
écrits dans cette conversion est tous
bien sûr qu'on a des droits et des
devoirs tous les deux voir associer
cette convention et puis aussi un moyen
de les ouvrir sur le monde d'ouvrir à
l'extérieur et puis de commencer a alors
donné une culture du citoyen les
premiers gestes de citoyens depuis 2006
la commune est aussi ville amie des
enfants
ce titre créé en 2002 c'est l'unicef qui
l'attribuent nous apporte des formations
nous apporte des kits condé propres des
enfants donc c'est un partenariat entre
la ville de lyon court et puis et
l'unicef donc dans le cadre de ce pacte
dans le cadre de ce partenariat
donc le dossier qui va être renouvelé en
décembre on va les articulés autour de
plusieurs thèmes dont qu'est la lutte
contre l'exclusion
le bien-être de l'enfant la qualité de
l'éducation
on est capable de proposer sur youtube
et bien sûr tous les partenariats qu'on
construira avec l'unicef
après versailles et saint germain en
laye guyancourt est l'une des premières
communes à avoir fait partie de ce
réseau dans les yvelines
au total 250 communes de france
bénéficient de ce titre de ville amie
des enfants dont 14 sont yvelinoise nous
accueillons donc philippe journée quand
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de
communication au sein de la délégation
des yvelines de l'unicef et vous êtes
avec nous aujourd'hui ce vendredi 20
novembre journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant
qu'est ce que ça signifie alors la
journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant
c'est pas nouveau puisque ça fait 30 ans
qu'on mène c'était une action
particulière pour l'enfance pourquoi
parce que jusqu'à une date finalement
récente jusqu'au début du siècle les
enfants n'avaient aucun droit aucun
n'était pas reconnue on se souvient des
de leurs conditions de travail dans les
mines anglaise au xviiie siècle et même
au début du 19ème
donc il a fallu vraiment que quelqu'un
se penche largement c'est un
pédopsychiatre polonais d'ailleurs qui
qui s'est penché sur la condition des
enfants ils s'appellent eux monsieur
jack et c'est lui qui a mis en place
toute une
mme étude sur les conditions des enfants
et conditions qui jusqu'en 1979 ça a été
la première déclaration des droits de
l'enfant à l'onu s'améliorer largement
les choses et la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
qui a été donc adopté le 20 novembre
1989 à l'unanimité c'est la première
fois qu'un traité portant sur des
conditions humanitaires est ainsi est
ainsi adopté par l'onu
il a fallu attendre 1989 pour que des
droits précis soit reconnue aux enfants
et qu'il soit adapté dans les
législations nationales parce qu'avant
il y avait un grand texte promulgué par
l'onu concernant les droits de l'enfance
mais les pays en faisaient ce qu'ils
voulaient ils appliquaient ne l'appliqué
pas aujourd'hui la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
qui a été ratifié par ces pays par 195
pays 196 pays maintenant état d' et est
adaptée dans la législation nationale en
france on adapte la législation a été
adapté avec la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant
du coup voilà revenu en france et avec
la crise sanitaire particulièrement dans
les yvelines comment l'unicef s'est
adapté pour cette journée est ce qu'il
ya eu quelque chose d'organisé en
particulier avec ces conditions
difficiles dues aux qu'ovide alors c'est
extrêmement compliqué à faire quelque
chose à créer des événements comme on en
avait l'habitude les précédentes années
il y à là destin la distanciation social
mais néanmoins avec les moyens modernes
de communication le net les le web etc
on a pu par exemple participé ce matin à
un webinaire à destination des
enseignants et des responsables
d'établissements scolaires webinaire
organisé par le rectorat de versailles
c'était très intéressant sas a débuté à
9 heures il ya les leurs le représentant
du défenseur des droits qui intervenait
cet après-midi pour mieux comprendre
là ces ide la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant comment
l'appliquer dans les écoles comment la
faire valoir comment la porter on a
besoin d'instituteurs de professeurs
pour la porter dans les écoles parce que
nous en tant qu unicef
on peut intervenir dans les écoles on à
l'habilitation pour intervenir dans les
écoles il ya un texte qui a été signé
une convention qui a été signée avec
l'éducation nationale
mais ce sont d'abord les professeurs qui
doivent mettre en avant c'est de
l'importance de des droits de l'enfant
parlons un petit peu de ce titre de
ville amie des enfants c'est l'unicef
donc ils attribuent ces les communes qui
en font la demande et du coup un lourd
dossier administratif
quels sont les autres actions de
l'unicef sont 18es et ce que vous nous
dire un petit mot sur ce titre de ville
amie des enfants dont on a entendu le
reportage que guyancourt va en refaire
la demande alors les villes amies des
enfants c'est un mandat de six ans adam
ça dure le temps d'une mandature
électoral et à chaque après chaque
élection municipale il faut refaire un
dossier pour que l'équipe municipale en
place soit d'accord pour accompagner les
programmes à destination des enfants
bien évidemment mettre en avant les
programmes aident l'unicef a participé à
des actions dans ces villes par exemple
des marchés de noël des plaidoyers dans
les écoles ou dans les centres de
loisirs par exemple il va y avoir dans
le cadre du 20 novembre après doyer que
je vais faire en visioconférence avec la
ville de conflans sainte honorine
ça sera fait le 25 novembre les autres
années c'est dans une salle de cinéma
que ça se produit il ya 600 enfants qui
sont réunis dans la salle
cette fois ça va se faire par
visioconférence mais on veut absolument
faire quelque chose il ya des
municipalités qui se drapent leur mairie
de bleu pour le pour l'occasion et puis
c'est également dans les établissements
scolaires les jeunes ambassadeurs de
l'unicef qui ont une
cette année particulièrement une rôle
essentiel à jouer puisque c'est eux qui
vont faire vraiment vivre la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
alors il ya plusieurs établissements
scolaires des désirs une plusieurs
lycées le lycée international
le lycée bascans à rambouillet le lycée
de la celle saint cloud le lycée
corneille à la celle saint cloud ou
encore le lycée de poissy qui ont un
rôle important à jouer les professeurs
mène des actions avec les enfants il ya
des expositions ddd vente au profit de
l'unicef etc et l'unicef a écrit
récemment une lettre au président de la
république est ce que vous nous en dire
un petit mot rapidement oui alors cette
lettre n'a pas été écrit uniquement par
l'unicef l'an passé
c'était à l'occasion des 30 ans de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
il ya une convention qui a été signée
une une association en quelque sorte de
13 mouvement qui milite en faveur de
l'enfant dont l'unique de l'enfance dont
l'unicef donc ça s'appelle de la
convention aux actes et cette année bien
en raison du coût vide notamment parce
que le coc vide marque un coup d'arrêt à
de nombreuses politique que nous menons
à destination des enfants mais pas
seulement l'unicef tous les pays toutes
les associations constatent la même
difficulté
il ya des besoins autres qui apparaît
c'est maintenant la nécessité d'aider
les enfants n'est parfois plus une
priorité dans dans certains pays dans
certaines collectivités besoin d'argent
à destination d'autres d'autres d'autres
secteurs c'est un peu ça peut se
comprendre
sauf que si on laisse tomber les enfants
aujourd'hui c'est l'avenir de demain qui
est en jeu je vois en matière
d'éducation par exemple en matière
d'éducation avec le co vide il ya 59
millions d'enfants dans le monde
bon je reviendrai en france très
rapidement sa 39 millions d'enfants qui
dans le monde ne peuvent pas aller à
l'école primaire n'ont pas accès à
l'école primaire
je ne parle pas du niveau secondaire où
il y en a encore moins où il y en a
encore plus qu'ils ne peuvent pas
accéder mais avec le co vide
des écoles se sont complètement arrêtée
ce sont des millions et des millions
d'enfants qui risque de ne pas pouvoir
revenir à l'école parce que le coup
d'arrêt il n'avait pas les moyens comme
en france de suivre sur internet dès des
cours par à distance et ben c'est des
enfants pour beaucoup perdu
malheureusement d'où votre lettre
président de la république pour revenir
rapidement où cette lettre de façon à ce
que la la politique de l'enfant soit une
véritable politique avec un véritable
ministère il ya eu un gros progrès
réalisés l'an passé avec la nomination
d'adrien taquet comme secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enfance mais c'est
insuffisant
il faut aller plus loin il faut que la
politique de l'enfant soit vraiment au
centre des préoccupations
gouvernementales bien le message est
passé merci philippe j'en ai quand
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce plateau
c'est moi qui vous remercie l'actualité
c'est aussi un nouveau prix pour l
encours la commune s'est vu décerné le
22 octobre dernier le prix territoria
d'or récompensant les services
numériques aux personnes développer
notamment lors du premier confinement
ont fait le point avec jean selles
fourgous le maire de la ville au micro
de mélanie poké à willencourt on se bat
depuis un centre d'année pour la
pédagogie mixtes c'est-à-dire une partie
en présentiel à l'école et une partie à
domicile on appelle les jeux distanciait
la pédologie présentiel il faut quatre
conditions
la première c'est d'abord d'avoir un
réseau de qualité il faut être fibrés
c'est le cas donc ça c'est les
institutions mairie qui a poussé à cela
bon ensuite il ya le rôle des profs
l'épreuve font une sur formation et
autres actions complémentaires en 10
arrivent elles encourent à saint-quentin
troisièmement il faut que l'enfant soit
très fort très bien formé aussi onu au
numérique et qu'il est il souhaiterait
aller relais avec une tablette on a
rajouté un café un élément qui a joué un
rôle pour obtenir ce premier prix
national c'est les parents on a formé
aussi les parents pour qu' il soit un
environnement ils fassent du
renforcement positif
[Musique]
il ya une bonne cohérence conseil
régional conseil départemental mairie
agglo et puis en même temps paris saclay
l'ensemble fait qu on est plutôt
performant sur la formation et on
accélère et c'est vrai que cette crise a
augmenté la culture numérique a augmenté
l'appétence ceci numérique aussi bien
des adultes que que des enfants dans
l'actualité sportive le départ du vendée
globe 2020 a été donnée le 8 novembre
dernier depuis les sables d'olonne comme
vous le savez un évinois participent à
cette édition
louis burton originaire de rambouillet
pour sa troisième participation à la
course le skipper du 60 18 s'en sort
plutôt bien
ce vendredi 20 novembre au moment de
cette émission
louis burton pointe à la sixième place
du classement
retour sur ces derniers jours en mer
avec michael et demi d'euros cette
deuxième semaine de compétition a été
moins éprouvante que la première pour
louis burton
cette fois ci pas de casse ni de faux
départ le skipper originaire de
rambouillet avance dans l'océan
atlantique en direction de l'équateur à
bord de son imoca bureau vallée deux
navigateurs profitent des conditions
climatiques plus clémentes
quand on arrive dans là l'idée sur lui
c'est vers part parce qu'on passe en
bonne salade n'était alors je
on
le manger du parti
et voilà
dujardin avec
et prend dix jours
le maïs
j'ai maison
et on va agrémenter
soir
dans la même journée louis burton a jeté
des capteurs dans l'océan pour
recueillir des données océanographiques
à partenariats créés entre son sponsor
la classe imoca et l'unesco
le lendemain le décor est moins
idyllique louis burton affronte le très
redouté pot-au-noir une zone de
convergence inter tropicale au large de
la côte ouest africaine
un secteur instable
[Musique]
après 13 jours de course louis burton
est toujours sixième du classement mais
remonte sur les premiers le vendée globe
2020 est toujours dominé par le
britannique alex thomson sur hugo boss
l'actualité de la semaine c'est bixente
mais rien senti steben qui vous la
résume en 78 secondes
le maire du chesnay rocancourt richard
delpierre a fait appel de la décision du
tribunal administratif d'annuler
l'élection municipale du 15 mars dernier
le recours avait été déposé par son
prédécesseur et adversaire lors des
municipales philippe brillault de
nouvelles élections pourraient être
organisées si cet appel est rejeté par
le conseil d'état auprès duquel la
sphère a été confiée huit centres de
dépistage sont déployés à proximité des
gares dignoise des tests anti génie qui
sont réalisés pour des résultats
communiqués en une vingtaine de minutes
les centres garde saint quentin en
yvelines et versailles chantiers sont
déjà effectifs un marché virtuel de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est la
promesse de l'application shop in sky
les commerçants des douze communes de
l'agglomération pourront s'y inscrire
gratuitement les clients commanderont
les produits sur l'application pour les
récupérer en magasin afin de favoriser
les commerces locaux
la protection maternelle et infantile
fête ce mois ci ses 75 ans assurant la
promotion de la santé de l'enfant et de
sa famille la médecine qui est effectué
et préventive gratuit pour les femmes
enceintes et les enfants jusqu'à 6 ans
les centres pmi sont au nombre de 23
dans les yvelines les possessions
tension activité ces dernières semaines
le nombre de colis est actuellement de
28 % plus élevé que ce qui était prévu
sur le circuit nor des yvelines cela
représente 35 mille colis par jour
traitées une hausse qui va entraîner le
recrutement de 30 personnes pour
supporter le black friday et noël
pour terminer ce journal c'est une
triste nouvelle que l'on a appris dans
le courant de la semaine
jean girard figure de la vie locale à
magny les hameaux s'est éteint le
week-end dernier président du comité
local de la fédération nationale des
anciens combattants d'afrique du nord il
aimait transmettre la mémoire de la paix
hommage avec mélanie poké et bixente
mais rien senti steban alors un gros
défaut objets mais je pense que je sais
pas si ça va on doit le dire j'ai une
grande gueule mais j'aime bien j'aime
bien dire ce que je pense mais je crois
que ça c'est aussi une force ma qualité
la qualité
j'aime bien les gens un personnage jean
girard indissociable de magny les
hameaux ici était installé en 1964
depuis il oeuvrait à travers plusieurs
engagements il avait des discussions qui
étaient très franche très directe mais
simplement parce que justement il aime
les gens ils voulaient que ça évite que
ça avance que que des problèmes
d'injustice soit réglé très vite et là
dessus il lâchait rien mais c'est à
travers deux créations qu'il laissera le
souvenir le plus fort le téléthon grâce
à sa mobilisation celle de son épouse et
de ses amis magny les hameaux battent
chaque année des records de dons j'aime
beaucoup les enfants
au début quand j'ai fait les premières
fois qu'on avait fait le téléthon
j'avais du mal à être auprès les enfants
handicapés papa qu'il ne faisait pas
loin de là au contraire mais c'était
j'avais ma larme
ceux qui portaient jean girard c'était
aussi la mémoire la sienne et celle de
ses amis anciens combattants en 1997 il
crée le comité local de la fnaca jean
girard est appelé en juillet 1958 il
passera 22 mois en algérie le formidable
qui avait sonné semaine camaraderie le
matin les gradés ont salué pas on se
hait la main les gamins
nous on poser tout un tas de questions
et où on leur dit toujours à chaque fois
la paix ne vous battez pas dans la cour
de récréation ne vous bagarrer pas
parler discuter expliquer vous met le
feu dans la guerre
un investissement qui mènera à la
création d'un carré de mémoire en 2015
une génération depuis plus de 20 ans ont
eu affaire à lui finalement et on a pris
un peu de leur citoyenneté disparu le 15
novembre dernier que jean girard avait
82 ans
la ville lui avait promis et l'a promis
à ses amis de la fnaca
le travail autour de la mémoire et de la
paix continuera
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un très
bon week end et une très bonne soirée
[Musique]